Gavin Newsom who obviously is going to
run and who is actively trying to take
out uh Joe Biden this weekend uh well
they asked him he was doing a talk and
someone asked him well why is everyone
leaving Cali if you're such a great dude
and listen to this pure abject horse
poop lie are more people leaving
California for Texas we're leaving Texas
for California well we lost about 182
000 folks in the last but how do you
explain that against the backdrop of
those very remarkable statistics you
just cited many factors and there's been
two deep analysis that drives the number
one factor the most the vast majority of
almost the entire amount impacted
because of the Visa policies and the
Trump Administration this whole damn
border debate is made up
it's made up
where's Congress where the hell are they
having done their job
he's soulless it's the only way to
describe him the the light that is in
all of us that has something to do with
truth has been extinguished and he is an
evil reptilian monster so now first off
360
000 people left California last year we
just checked while he was talking 360
000. so he lied about the number and
then he completely lies about why
it had something to do with the Trump
Visa program uh Connor when you were
when we were packing up and everything
did anything to do with the Trump Visa
program Phoenix Trump Daphne did you
know about the Trump Visa
yeah we left because Los Angeles had
turned into a dystopian nightmare of
crime and lockdowns and drugs and just
the worst of what a society could be
well I can't say the worst because San
Francisco is worse and that is what his
job was he was the mayor of San
Francisco before Los Angeles people fled
California and are fleeing California in
droves because of high taxes
mismanagement fires uh electrical
outages you are a horrible horrible
person Gavin Newsom and you've always
been a horrible person here's Gavin
Newsom I like this one well done today
Phoenix here's Gavin Newsom back in 2008
promising to end homelessness in 10
years we believe fundamentally that food
solves hunger that shelters solve sleep
and that housing solves homelessness and
if we're going to solve the problem of
those that are out on the streets that
we Define as homeless we better solve
the housing a problem if we're going to
have an impact and that's why we
established this framework what we call
a 10-year plan to end chronic homeless
in San Francisco okay not only did he
not do that he actually did the reverse
he destroyed San Francisco don't forget
it know it share it with your
brainwashed friends like Joy Behar I
love the line food solves hunger it's so
brilliant food solves hunger what are we
having for lunch today by the way should
we do a little Chick-fil-A maybe we'll
discuss uh food sells over housing
solves homelessness
meaningless drivel which makes him the
perfect Democrat actually that's not yes
food at some level what if the Democrats
are very very good at at this level
right base level they can get say
something that makes sense food stops
hunger and then they go oh my God food
sunsoft hunger when I'm hungry I have
food I have a Snickers bar and then I
don't want to punch somebody okay that's
that is sort of right and housing solves
homelessness well I suppose if you
didn't have a house and you were
homeless and then they gave gave you a
house you wouldn't be homeless so that
sort of works at that level all you have
to do is think about it for a half a
second more and realize that these are
just meaningless dribble slogans are you
going to endlessly give people food and
would that solve the food shortage
problem uh are you going to endlessly
give people housing or is it possible
that these people have deep
psychological problems often that they
have massive drug addiction problems
that you haven't created the conditions
for them to get good high-paying jobs so
that more bill or you have over
regulation of buildings so that the
contractors who want to come in and
build better houses and innovate don't
want to even come to your city he is a
liar he has been wrong at absolutely
everything forever